ask yourself a simple question is the
world around you real
it seems like the answer should be
pretty obvious of course the world as
you know it is real
how else would you be able to interact
with it perhaps a better question would
be this
how much do you trust that the world you
know
is real how much do you believe that
reality
as you experience it is constant and
cannot be changed by external forces
now imagine if you can an entity to
which the very fabric of reality is
like clay able to be shaped and molded
at will
then imagine that this entity this
malicious twisted
and unknowable horror has taken a
special
interest in you if you can picture such
a scenario
then you may as well be standing in the
shoes of james talaran
a foundation researcher assigned to
scp-3999
talaran could only have imagined what
the foundation kept contained in an
airtight cell
all the way at the bottom of a kilometer
long shaft and never expected that this
was where his lifeless body
would be found despite having the entity
contained
the foundation's only knowledge of
scp-3999
came from a text document discovered on
taloran's phone
after his demise even their own records
indicated that no such creature
ever existed why what could possibly
shape reality in such a way that it
could hide its own existence from the
foundation
and where was it now the document on
tolerance phone yielded some evidence
seeming to be a long rambling and
confused account of some sort of battle
between a reality-shaping entity and the
ill-fated researcher
sent to examine it unlike many of the
foundation's documents
the entry for scp-3999 is riddled with
contradictions and strikethroughs
a confusing mess of information that
makes piecing together the mysteries of
tolerance fade
all the more difficult beneath the
strange formatting and uncertainty
surrounding
scp-3999 lies the tale of one man's
torture for the amusement of an
impossibly powerful
and eternally sadistic creature based on
the information available
it appears that scp-3999 was fixated on
talaran
upon his arrival to the entity's cell
the researcher had no idea how long he
would spend in the company of scp-39
or that he would never emerge alive many
scps contained by the foundation require
their own
specially made prisons in order to hold
them and maintain the safety of
foundation staff as well as the outside
world
but imagine if an scp could turn the
tables
bending the world around a single member
of the foundation
using all of reality as their own
personalized torture chamber
the list of horrors endured by talaran
is both exhaustive and
incomplete given the length of time he
spent with the creature
shortly after james talaran was assigned
to site 118
where scp-3999 was contained
the entity was somehow able to breach
containment and began to twist the world
around it
in the name of a singular cruel
objective
the torture of james talaran
the creature while having no physical
description possessed the capability to
cause either a ck-class reality
restructuring event or a zk
class end of reality event scp-3999 was
somehow able to both destroy reality
itself
while simultaneously rebuilding it
around its prisoner
researcher talaran every creature
person and machination that scp-3999
created was done so with the express
intention of making tolerance suffer
horribly
over the course of millions of years
according to the researchers own
writings
the exact details of how scp-3999
tortured talaran are littered throughout
the document he was found with
but it is apparent that the entity was
able to use its reality altering
abilities to continually revive the man
after killing him
as a way to prolong his pain
scp-3999 seemed to be able to use its
powers however it pleased but focused
all its attention
and actions on causing misery for one
man
it simply enjoyed inflicting suffering
one of the examples of the atrocities
james tolerance suffered at the mercy of
a cold remorseless creature
was witnessing the deaths of others
although they were constructed and
controlled by scp-3999
tolerance saw trained foundation
security personnel drag
three people into the cell he recognized
them instantly as his own family
taloran was made to watch as his mother
father
and sister were executed with a single
gunshot to the head by members of the
same organization that he was a part of
all of talarant's professional
colleagues were also killed in front of
him
followed by anyone and everyone that had
come into contact with james talaran
including the o5 council he was made to
watch as they were systematically
murdered one by one
all for the enjoyment of scp-3999
at some point during the creatures
torture of talaran there appears to have
been some attempt to contain
scp-3999 within another scp
scp-2432 a room within a hotel now owned
by the foundation that appears to compel
its guests to write exaggerated positive
reviews
after staying there when introduced to
scp-2432
scp-3999's ability to alter reality
seemed to have the effect of creating a
dimensional anomaly within the hotel
a space opened up in scp-2432
leading to an almost identical room the
front door of this new room
designated scp-2432-1
led to an alternate dimension that
resembled the hotel housing
scp-2432 the rooms of this new version
of the scp-2432 hotel
were a seemingly infinite endless loop
of rooms
this dimension also played host to a
number of strange creatures as
uncovered by foundation research teams
that ventured there
most notably a creature resembling a
male homo sapien
calling itself researcher talaran this
being was dressed in clothing similar to
foundation researchers
and appeared nervous and confused when
approached by personnel
only to be executed when asked to be
told the location of
scp-3999 later during scp-3999's three
million year torture session
james talaran was interviewed with
another doctor working for the
foundation
the interviewing doctor had no
recollection of tolerance assignment to
scp-3999
and both james's involvement with the
foundation and the very existence of
scp-39
were expunged from the foundation's
database
as talaran desperately tried to
rationalize what was happening to him
he told the interviewer i have trouble
focusing on things now
i just feel a lot of unease it's like
reality has started to feel
less real if that makes sense
shortly after he attempted to ask the
doctor for his name
and for him to identify which of the
foundation sites they were at
in response the doctor admitted a
strange noise from his mouth
confusing talaran that's not a name you
just made a noise with your mouth
the researcher replied why am i thinking
of redactions
how can a word be redacted like that in
a normal conversation
following this the floor beneath james
taloran's feet disappeared
and he was swallowed by darkness as
scp-3999 continued bending reality to
make him suffer
what followed were multiple failed
attempts from talaran to either escape
from the entity or nullify its abilities
to warp reality
scp-3999 had at a later point trapped
talaran in a stage play version of
itself
as james frantically tried to escape out
of a nearby door where he hoped to find
reality
he was met with a solid wall i'm trapped
in whatever this place is with this
thing
and there's no outside reality anymore
he realized
researcher talaran tried to understand
the entity but scp-3999 defied
description
it was simply chaos in his desperation
talaran was able to dig a tiny hole in
the floor through which he could see a
light
filled with thoughts of his beloved
family his colleagues and the rest of
the world that had once existed
he opened the hole wider it is unclear
what happened after this
but it is apparent that james talaran
was still unable to escape
scp-3999 however as the situations he
found himself in grew increasingly
strange
james talaran was able to take greater
control of his predicament
this is evidence in the foundation's
document regarding scp-3999
researcher talaran cannot be contained
by this researcher taloran will fight
his way back
researcher talaran will recontain
scp-3999
this torture had gone on long enough and
researcher james talaran was determined
to be free of the creature that had
taken such sick pleasure in his pain
taloran at one point was able to subdue
scp-3999
although it is initially unclear how he
accomplished this
there were several attempts made to
contain the entity using a recursive
joke
a melon the graves of american crime
novelist robert b
parker or an o5 council member and a
roach motel
it is believed that every single one of
these attempts failed
attempting to beat the creature at its
own game talarant tried to turn
scp-3999's reality altering powers
against it by imagining the entity as
something easier to subdue
these included several moldy blankets a
murderous penguin
and a pillow eventually telerin was able
to contain
scp-3999 with the aid of 48 train
containment personnel
all of whom were also researcher talaran
during this time a conversation between
the two were partially recorded
although any dialogue from scp-3999
suffered from data corruption
claiming to finally be in charge and in
control of the situation
talaran interrogated scp-3999
berating the creature for keeping him
prisoner you can't frighten me anymore
for the first million years of
nonsensical containment procedures and
tortures and dream logic
it was the worst pain i had ever felt
but i survived
for the second million years it was
still the hardest thing i had ever done
but i survived by the third million
years
i was growing numb the researcher tried
to ascertain the exact nature and origin
of scp-3999
but to no avail vowing to fight the
entity
tolerant told it here's the thing about
horror and weirdness
the more you reveal of it the less
effect it has
i am sick of your horror
i am sick of you afterwards
he was melted into goo for five years it
appears that shortly after this
researcher taloran managed to understand
how to destroy
scp-3999 while the entity was immortal
and virtually unstoppable
he realized its weakness that it had to
bond to another being in order to
survive
upon discovering this talaran took his
own life
causing all that scp-3999 had done to
disappear
after foundation researcher james
talaran committed suicide
reality reverted to its original state
before
scp-3999 had heavily altered it
his death freeing reality from the evil
entity
once and for all the foundation remains
unaware of what
scp-3999 was or indeed
is and one can only guess as to why the
entity subjugated tolerant to such
terror
and horror what made this powerful
reality bender hold such a perverse
fixation on one man
some have likened the creature to a
horror rider continually subjugating a
character to all manner of nightmares
before deciding to re-draft and try
something new
whatever it was scp-3999 carries with it
a warning
that reality isn't always as it seems
check out scp-5000 the suit
and scp-106 the old man
for more horrifying tales from the scp
foundation